there's a trans woman sitting in the
audience
this is true story it was like a few
weeks ago i did six shows that weekend
this trans woman came to four of them
calls himself daphne
man this chick daphne was in there
cracking the [ __ ] up at everything i
said about everybody it was amazing she
was laughing and it was fun to watch her
laugh
you could tell she was letting go with
something that was heavy and she threw
her head back and she smiled with all
her teeth she was having a great time
and the more fun she had i felt bad
because i knew
i had some trans jokes on low
and i thought to myself maybe i
shouldn't say these jokes because i
don't want to like [ __ ] her evening up
she was having so much fun but then i
thought to myself well if i can't say it
in front of us should i say this [ __ ] at
all
so i let it rip
to my surprise
daphne laughed harder the trans jokes
than anybody in the room in fact
everybody in the room would look at her
to make sure it was okay
[Applause]
and
i got off stages in the dressing room i
was like well it's a [ __ ] weird show
i'm sitting in a dress room by myself
just trying to figure out like what what
the [ __ ] just happened out there like
why is it that this one woman can't take
any of these jokes and daphne can take
all of these jokes so weird and then i
realized ah
daphne used to be a man
so now i go out of the dressing room and
and like you can see like all the the
staff was there like cleaning the club
up the audience had gone and sitting at
the bar by herself who's daphne and
she's like hey
dave come join me for a drink and i
don't want to think that i'm transphobic
or nothing something like [ __ ] i i guess
i could have at least drink and we get
some tequila and we're sitting there
and and she was [ __ ] cool turns out
the daphne she wants to be a comedian
she was asking for advice i told her
advice and all that [ __ ] and then she
says to me she says boy you sure do get
a bad rap for your trans jokes
i said daphne thank you but you don't
have to say that i hope i didn't offend
you she goes no
no no no she said in fact i read about
you in the new york times i said you did
she said yeah she said i thought it was
interesting that they blamed you for r
kelly they said you normalized them for
telling jokes about them i go yeah yeah
they said that she goes i wonder why
they never said that she normalized
transgenders by telling jokes about us
[Music]
and i never thought about that it never
occurred to me and we started making out
and then like
i
i reached up just to see what it felt
like i was like oh what is what
and it felt like plus it did that was
just like
[Music]
question what the [ __ ]
[Music]
uh what am i going to do if trump's
getting reelected probably get a
significant tax break
hey
you wanna know why i don't even talk
about trump in my show because that
[ __ ] is not the hokey poker he
is not what it's all about there's
millions of people that put him in power
and the ideas that he puts forth uh are
not his own
he's singing poor white people's
greatest hits so why the [ __ ] when i
worry about him and now the other
millions
really you know who i'm gonna vote for
next time if things keep going the way
it's going is that gay dude
no mike pence
[Applause]
now this is the same club the punchline
it's 15 years ago and i just gotten back
from from my infamous uh south africa
trip and i came to the punch line just
to cheer myself up it's a safe place
where i can tell some jokes
and
i find out that this comedian i know
chris tucker who's in all those rush
hour movies i find out that chris is in
san francisco too at some charity event
so i call him like yo i just saw you at
some charity event i said i'm doing a
show at the punchline why don't you come
by the club after your event is that
cool dave i thought she was dead [ __ ]
i'll come by he said
he says is it okay if i bring some
friends cause you know i'm with a lot of
people like man you chris tucker you can
bring whoever the [ __ ] you want
and then i show up to the club
late that night i walk into the dressing
room
and sit in the dressing room
is uh gavin newsom who at the time was
the mayor of san francisco but now he's
the governor of california
and sitting next to him was kamala
harris who at the time was the d.a of
san francisco now she's the senator from
california that's front running on the
democratic ticket
and sit next to her was al gore
it's [ __ ] weird
sitting next to al gore was the guys
from google sergey and i don't know how
to say these
all right
and it was chris tucker and and ben
jealous who at the time was the
president of the naacp
who was all just at this big charity
dinner and and and paul moody was
drinking scotch
and we all was just in there and
you know first i was a little
uncomfortable we started talking and we
all got along really well
at some point uh
come on harris says she says to me she
goes you know a friend of mine is
announcing his candidacy for president
tomorrow i went to college with him
what i go barack obama she goes you've
heard of him like yo i just read about
this dude and she goes yo yeah blah we
talking she goes you know what she says
let's
let's call him on the phone i said what
the [ __ ]
and she picks the phone up and she downs
and she's listening like this and she
goes ah
this is
voicemail and she gives me phone she
goes leave him a message
you know i didn't know what to say i
just said what you say to any black dude
is
running for president you know stay low
running his exact pattern this kind of
[ __ ]
[Applause]
and then the last thing i say is you
know what i said sir well i really do
believe you can do this like man i'm
wishing you luck
now
next day i wake up and go for coffee at
a place called the embarcadero it's like
an eatery by the sea in san francisco
and i'm walking to the coffee shop and
there's a police line and i can't cross
the tape but then i figure i have
[ __ ] i'm dave chappelle so i go into
the thing like this
and the police yoke me this
[ __ ] like tackle me immediately
and i see
over the police's shoulder gavin newsom
i couldn't remember his name but i
remember last the night before i had
kept teasing him and saying he looked
like christian bale the guy from the
batman movies
uh so i see him and i can't remember
anything so i'm just like batman help
[Applause]
and he stops he's like dave
and and then the police see that the
mayor knows me so they're all like oh
sorry about that
and he's like back up everybody and he
just picks me up he's like i'm really
sorry about that i'm like i'm fine don't
worry about it and he's like he's like
listen i'm here with the prince would
you like to meet him i'm like i know
prince that's my [ __ ]
and we go around the corner and it was
prince charles the prince of england
i didn't know the protocol of meeting
royalty you're not supposed to touch
them i dapped them up like a [ __ ] mine
[ __ ]
just hugging them and [ __ ] like this
dapping them up
and that [ __ ] was cool too that's
really [ __ ] weird
and then i was just out there in the
upside down not having no tv show trying
to figure life out and the election was
going on in the background and this guy
barack obama was picking up steam
this [ __ ] was killing it
and i had a chance to go to the last
debate on the democratic ticket and i
went it's me and chris tucker
sitting in myrtle beach south carolina
it's the last three candidates it was
barack obama john edwards and hillary
clinton
now obama's a lot taller than edwards
and clinton and he had the center podium
and at one point they're all on stage
and they start fussing and obama goes
look
none of us are perfect like this his
hands was like this and there was light
shining behind his head and the other
two candidates was looking up his [ __ ]
and i was sitting in the audience like
this [ __ ] looks like jesus
[Applause]
and i realized
in that moment
that i was looking at the next president
of the united states i was certain of it
i couldn't explain it
but i knew what i was seeing
and i got really excited and i'm not
that kind of guy i said i gotta meet
this [ __ ]
so i stayed
they were all on stage doing interviews
and i just waited i was waiting and
waiting and then
john edwards was done with his
interviews first because everybody knew
he wasn't going to win
and i see john edwards and i said hey
hey senator edwards i just want to say
hi and that [ __ ] look at me like
hmm
[ __ ] even though he's gonna lose anyway
and then he left and then hillary
clinton just walked by me and won the
steve harvey suits
[Applause]
but obama was taking forever
everybody wanted to talk to him when i
knew the media saw exactly what i saw
there was no question about it dad was
the guy
i waited and i waited and finally must
have been over an hour and a half he
finished his last interview he was like
well thank you very much good talking to
you
and he turns around
and he's we make eye contact he sees me
and when he sees me he looks up he goes
dave chappelle
and and obama did me the same way i did
prince charles
he like bro hugged me and he pulled me
in and i'll never forget this he said in
my ear
i got your message
thank you very
much good night